- We're shooting a video trying
out different hats and stuff,
how do you think I look?
- Uh, it's a hat.
- How do you think I look?
(girl shrieks)
(upbeat music)
- Today the Try Guys are going bald,
which is something that
happens to most men.
- [Voiceover] Alright,
you guys ready to go bald?
- I was born bald, I'm
ready to be bald again.
- Going bald for me, it's
not a question of "if,"
it's probably a question of "when."
Hair loss runs in my family,
it is something that is happening to me.
It's very common among Jewish men.
I think that's why Jews
started wearing yarmulkes,
to cover up their bald spot.
There was a long time that
I didn't care about my hair,
and I didn't care about it
until I realized I was losing it.
I look back at photos,
and like, it's going.
So it's something I've
been trying to combat,
but it's also something I've been trying
to come to terms with.
It makes me feel bad.
- I have a little bit of
thinning starting here.
I guess going bald crosses
my mind every so often.
I'm afraid that my head
is an ugly lump of skin.
I think my main concern
is that I have this mole
on the back of my head that
you've never seen likely
because I always make sure my hair
is cut long enough to cover that mole.
I don't care that much
about my actual hair,
but I do care about how I look.
And being bald with a big mole on my head
would change how I look.
I'll be ugly.
- My grandfather has
lost a lot of his hair,
so it's probably something
that's in my future.
To just jump straight to what I'm gonna
look like 50 years from now,
that's gonna be shocking.
My fear today is that my wife
is gonna think I'm hideous,
because when you're in love with someone,
like, "Oh, I'll love you no
matter what you look like."
But now we're gonna test that assumption.
Will she still find me
attractive? I don't know.
- I think when people
describe me physically,
the first thing they say is hair.
Second probably Asian,
but first I'd say hair.
When I was young, when I
felt very unattractive,
the one thing people always said to me
was I had great hair.
So, I kinda have this attachment to it.
My hair is kinda like another appendage.
Kinda like the boobs of my
head, so eyes down here.
I just have very specific
features that look really stern.
My personality is softened by
the way my hair is presented.
I feel like without my
hair, I'm not gonna be me.
(rock music)
- Today what I'm interested to see
is what would I actually
look like when I'm bald.
Maybe it's not so bad.
- Let's do this: three, two, one.
(laughs)
What a nightmare.
Oh wow, that is one ugly fella.
It's not as bad as I thought it would be,
it's a lot smoother than I thought.
Woah, that's a feeling.
That mole is big.
(growls)
Well, that's sort of how
I fear my mole to appear.
My ears are so much more prominent.
If it's not one insecurity, it's another.
- Alright, I'm ready.
Holy shit. (chuckles)
Oh no, I don't like that at all.
It looks like a different person.
I've never seen myself without hair.
This just isn't me; it doesn't
feel like my personality.
I'm astounded.
I've never been this
floored by a transformation.
I look like every martial arts character,
like I'm gonna kill somebody.
Okay, I'm done.
- So my father has kind of
more of like around the side.
I'm gonna try and get as
close to that today as we can.
The hope is a sexy Bruce
Willis or Vin Diesel type.
I'd probably look more like a baby turtle.
Let's meet future Zach.
Oh, no.
Oh man, I look like Dr. Phil
and the kid from Jerry Maguire had a baby.
There are no words for
how much I dislike this.
This is a real hit to my confidence, guys.
How can I look like this and
confidently talk to people?
I'm really pretty speechless.
I'm pretty stunned.
Fuck.
- Confidence is sexy right?
So if I'm gonna rock
the Friar Tuck haircut,
then you can call me Friar Fuck.
One, two, three (yells).
Oh no.
(dramatic choral music)
Oh, I hate it.
Oh, isn't that sad?
Why do I just feel awful about myself
just 'cause my hair changed?
Oh, I don't want to be
friends with myself.
Check out the back.
Ooh, sexy.
She's not going to like this;
she's gonna be horrified.
What if actually lose my
hair and then she divorces me
'cause she thinks I'm ugly?
I'm being silly, but
also somewhat serious.
I just want to crawl
into bed and not wake up.
- As much as guys like to
act like they don't care
about how their hair looks,
I think every guy really,
truly, deeply cares
about what their hair looks like.
It's way more deep than we allow ourselves
to admit as a society, especially as men.
We're stepping into a lot
of different shoes here,
not only into male insecurity,
but there's a lot of people out there
when it comes to cancer, alopecia
who can't control the fact
that they are losing hair.
I'm interested to see
how people will react.
- I'm not looking forward
to what everyone else is gonna
think and say about this.
- We're going to the office to see
how people like how I look.
- I think it's kinda getting used to it.
- Alright, I'm going to go
show some friends what I look like.
- You've done some things in your day,
this is not one of them
you should be doing.
- Do you think some people
look okay as bald men?
- Is this like divorce for a week?
No one can pull this off.
(girl yells)
- What do you think?
- I think that was my honest opinion.
- Woah, look at you without hair.
- Dream come true right here.
- What's the dream?
- I secretly pray that your
hair falls out, every day.
This is just bad for everybody.
- I was really looking forward
to my coworkers helping me,
telling me that it was okay to be balding,
that I'm still beautiful.
And so far, that has not happened.
The opposite has happened; I feel awful.
- I look like a bald Thomas Jefferson.
- Fact is, I don't give
a fuck what people think.
If this is how I look, don't
deserve me at my worst,
can't handle me at my best.
- The more I see it, the less I'm as upset
by all of us honestly.
- You look really good, you look so good.
- I think I look really mean.
- Yeah, of course.
- This is amazing. How do you feel?
- Actually, now that
I'm walking around more,
I kind of enjoy it.
- You look dope. Why
does he look cool still?
I thought that hair was like
90% of it, but it's not.
- What do you think?
- I think you have a
really good shaped head.
- Yeah?
- That was the thing I was worried about
when I was going bald.
- Yeah, it's like, what if my head's ugly?
- Absolutely.
- (Laughs) This is the best image.
- We all look adorable.
- Honestly, yours looks
regal and dignified.
- You're the first
person to complement me.
- Oh really?
- When did you go bald?
- I started going bald when I was 21.
- 21?
- Yeah, it threw me off.
- But you look great.
- Well thank you.
- I have no problem; this looks fine.
I just don't know how I
feel about the ponytail.
- Now that I know that my head
doesn't have any lumps or anything.
I would get a lot of
haircuts, like very tight.
- This works for you;
if you have to shave your
head, you're gonna be...
- [Keith] I'm gonna be okay?
- Even if people are
shocked, I don't give a fuck.
- Yeah, just own it.
- You've been so confident
throughout this whole thing.
- I don't know how everybody
else is gonna feel about it.
- When did you see it?
- So early.
So I'm back at home, and I'm going
to surprise Ariel with my new look.
- So I'm standing on a
street corner as cars go by
to see if anybody gives me a second look.
- I guess without hair I don't really need
to deal with this section.
I can go to what's most important, bam.
- Giving myself a hair cut,
kind of putting control back in my hands,
we're gonna see if people
react to me little better.
I feel like I look like a respectable dad.
- You look so happy.
- This is like a cool dad.
- Kind of like the dad from
"Honey, We Shrunk the Kids."
(Coworkers agree)
- You look like a director
of a big time movie.
- Oh, you cut the sides?
- You've always had a
really cute, boyish face,
that doesn't change.
- It looks a lot better.
- Yeah, it looks so much better.
- You heard it here
first, totally fuckable,
I look great like this.
- The checkout clerk
actually recognized me
even without my hair.
Do you actually think
this looks attractive?
- [Clerk] Very sexy.
- Oh, very sexy. Oh man.
- Nobody seems to be giving two shits
about what I look like.
It's not that big a deal,
or I'm so ugly they can't even look at me.
- My neighbors might think I'm
a person trying to break in.
- Oh my god.
It looks so real.
- [Ned] So do you think
you would still love me
if I started losing my hair like this?
- I would love you no matter what.
Would you love me if I
started losing my hair?
- [Ned] I would, yes.
(rap music)
- What do you think, Ariel?
- [Ariel] I think you look great.
- [Ariel] Yeah.
(rap music)
- As I adopted a more confident attitude,
it became easier to own my hairstyle.
And the people that know you best
are the people that are
gonna care the least.
- People fixate on their negatives
and they get downtrodden by it,
but I think if you look at your negatives
and think of a way to find positivity.
You can't choose what happens to you,
but you can choose what you do.
- My biggest takeaway is that
my hair doesn't make up my identity.
Bald, full head of hair, whatever you are:
just fucking like yourself
and fuck anyone else who says otherwise.
- When we started this video
by talking about how for men,
and for me in particular,
this is probably my biggest concern.
I've seen what that might look like,
and it's really not that scary.
- You're not mad at dad.
(Everyone laughs)
- I see how it is, so you
like bald but not balding.
- That's how it is?